Hello, if you want to know what LoRA is and how
it helps us to finetune huge language models
such as GPT3 or LLaMA, then this video is right
for you! LoRA is short for Low-Rank Adaptation
and comes in really handy, because: The cool
chatbots and language models that we have
been using, such as ChatGPT, LLaMA 2, Claude,
Falcon, and so on, are very general purpose.
Prompting them correctly by
asking the question right,
plus showing them some examples
in the input only gets us so far
and usually works for domains that the
model has already seen in pretraining.
To really specialize them for a
task or to a different domain to
make them become a banking chatbot and get
financial skills, or a medical chatbot,
we want to finetune them on our
smaller dataset, such as, idk,
transcripts of videos from this channel if we want
the LLaMA model to impersonate Ms. Coffee Bean.
But when finetuning
large language models – at least the open source
ones which we can download – we quickly run into
a problem with their size: Highly capable Large
Language Models are huge because they contain
tens to hundreds of billions of parameters.
And during finetuning, we need to load all these
parameters into our GPU (just like for inference),
but we also need roughly
double the amount of space
to save the respective gradient for
each parameter. Just as a reminder of
basic neural network training: we need
the gradients during backpropagation to
adapt the weights according to the loss we
computed on instances from the new task.
[How LoRA works] But with LoRA, we can finetune
large models with only a fraction of the cost.
LoRA was introduced by this paper from Microsoft
and is surprisingly less complicated than expected
and we’ll explain it. It works like this:
With LoRA, instead of modifying all these
model weights during finetuning,
we freeze them, meaning that we leave
them unchanged and do not do anything
to the copy of the downloaded model.
Instead, we add a separate set of weights.
These finetuned weights after an ideal LoRA
training process, represent the differences
we need to add to the pretrained parameters
to make the model perfect for solving the
finetuning task. But come on, what did we do?
We now have doubled the number of parameters
on our hard drive. Yes, but it is double the
amount on our hard drive and not on our GPU.
On our GPU, when we load the finetuned model
for inference, we add the fine-tuned
weights to the pre-trained weights,
so we still have one set of weights for
inference in our video memory, not two.
The finetuned weights can be seen as modifications
to the original weights which we can merge into
the model if needed. Okay, so during inference
we did not increase the need of memory for
our GPU, but how do we finetune the network
and adjust these additional difference parameters
and how can this be more efficient, since their
number is the same as the original number of
parameters? Well, this is the trick in LoRA: it
reduces the number of trainable parameters. How?
Well, you maybe know
that a layer in a neural network is a
matrix multiplication to the input of the layer
plus the addition of a so-called bias vector,
followed by a nonlinear operation. The weights of
the network are the entries of the matrix, which
are the numbers we need to adjust in training or
finetuning. The larger the number of parameters,
the larger the matrices, so GPT-3 with 175 billion
parameters has much larger matrices than GPT-2 of
“only” 1.5 billion parameters.
Now, every matrix has a rank,
which is a number counting how many linearly
independent columns the matrix has. Linearly
dependent means that we can get that column by
combining other columns from the matrix. If we
remove linearly dependent columns from the matrix,
we reduce the matrix dimension, but without losing
information – because that information was
already there since we can get that linearly
dependent column from other columns in the matrix.
So LoRA’s idea is that we do not need to optimize
the full rank matrices that have high dimensions,
thus a lot of numbers, but rather we should do
a low rank decomposition, by representing these
weights as the multiplication of two matrices A
and B. We gain computational efficiency, because
A and B together contain less numbers than the
original weight matrix – in this example we have
6 numbers instead of 9 – thus these are less
numbers we need to tune. And the bigger the
original weight matrices, the higher the gains
from doing this decomposition to a low rank r.
The effect of writing delta W as a multiplication
of two smaller matrices A and B is that, we reduce
the dimensionality of the weight matrix through A,
thus we remove linearly dependent columns, and
we regain the original dimensionality through
B again. The hyperparameter we need to choose
is the rank r, because we do not know what the
intrinsic rank of the weight matrix is and we
implicitly remove hopefully linearly dependent
columns by the AB decomposition: if we choose
the rank too low, we reduce the dimensionality
too much and lose information, because we
implicitly deleted linearly independent columns.
If we choose it too high, we keep too many
parameters that are linearly dependent and
waste computation. We initialize A from a Gaussian
distribution and B with 0 and let backpropagation
figure out what the right numbers in the matrices
A and B are according to our finetuning objective.
So LoRA in a nutshell means that instead
of tuning the large weight matrix delta W,
we tune the smaller matrices A and B.
Told you that it is not super complicated!
So after we’ve found the finetuned
weights by optimizing A and B,
we should not forget to add
them to the original model
to make inference with the LoRA
finetuned model. And we’re done.
But why choose LoRA and not other
approaches that adapt models in a
parameter- and compute efficient way?
One common alternative to LoRA
is adding so-called Adapter Layers
in each Transformer block. During fine-tuning,
we only adapt the parameters of these layers and
leave the rest unchanged. Since these adapter
layers have very few parameters, even as few
as 1% of the transformer’s Feed forward layers,
it means that during training, it is very compute
efficient. But the problem is that large networks
are usually parallelized on hardware,
while adapter layers must be processed
sequentially. This means that during inference,
adapters introduce a noticeable latency.
Another common approach is prefix tuning
which is a continuous and automated version
of prompt engineering. Instead of manually
choosing the right words for the input to
prompt the model to give the right answer,
prefix tuning bypasses the word representation
step: We add input vectors that do not stand for
any words in particular, they are just vectors
that we initialize randomly and are called
prefix. We tune the entries of the vectors
with backpropagation until the model delivers the
correct answer. Compared to Prompt Engineering,
where the vectors represent words, in prefix
tuning they do not. The problem with prefix tuning
is that it occupies part of the sequence length
and reduces the size of the effective input. Also,
prefix tuning is difficult to optimize
and the number of trainable parameters is
hard to choose: if you delete parameters,
the performance can unexpectedly improve,
but also vice-versa, there is not a clear law.
So sure, Adapters or Prefix tuning are still very
popular, but since LoRA came out it has been only
increasing in popularity over the alternatives.
This was our little introduction to LoRA. Do not
forget to hit the like button if LoRA is clearer
to you now after watching this video. We hope
to see you next time, so subscribe! Okay, bye!